and the Oscar goes to Jean Dujardin  this is the first Academy Award and  nomination for Jean Dujardin well known  and celebrated in his native France  oh thank you way I love your country  okay thank you to the Academy uh it's  funny because in 1929 it wasn't Billy  Crystal but Douglas Fairbanks who stood  the first Oscar ceremony  tickets cost $5 and it lasted 15 minutes  times have changed  so thank you Douglas Fairbanks yes  Melissa your grandfather of spirit and  whether they've inspired me for this  role and so many of you here tonight  have inspired me Thank You Michele thank  you for this incredible gift thank you  my wonderful partner Bernice Vishal  Sakura the wonderful casting crew oh my  wife I love you kisses Simone Jill Chloe  and and if George Allen Todd Valentine  could speak it say Wow Rick - alien se  sorry dad - Sybil cool I love you